at the end of every episode of Journey
to the micro Cosmos we thank you for
coming on this journey with us as we
explore the Unseen World that surrounds
us but have you ever found yourself
wanting to have your own journey and
explore the Unseen World that surrounds
you well you can start on your own
Journey with the micro Cosmos microscope
we worked with our master of microscopes
James Weiss to design what we believe is
the perfect starter microscope for
someone who wants to get into microscopy
in fact the clip you're seeing on the
screen right now was captured using our
microscope we'll have a whole video
coming out pretty soon where we talk
more about our microscope and show you
what it's capable of but for now if
you'd like to know more or pick one up
for yourself you can go to
microcosmos.store
foreign
[Music]
if you have been venturing through the
micro Cosmos for some time now these
oval green shapes likely seem familiar
to you they are not particularly
distinctive but they are green and big
enough to see under the microscope and
those two qualities describe a good
chunk of what we find in the micro
Cosmos these particular little green
organisms show up in the background of
other organisms lives providing pops of
color among debris and if you're
thinking about identifying what this is
you might turn to some of the obvious
candidates maybe a euglenoid or some
kind of algae something green and Rod
shaped and single-celled possibly
eukaryotic and if that's your guess we
would not blame you but you are wrong
what you are looking at is not a
single-celled organism but rather a
gathering of them those green bits are
consortia of bacteria we're going to
explain more about what is actually in
that consortia but before that we gotta
tell you what a Consortium is
first not all consortia are green some
are more like the colorless squiggle you
see in the middle of your screen made up
of thin curved prokaryotes gathering
around a central bacterium that has
flagella at both ends and Consortium is
kind of a funny word to describe
bacteria isn't it it makes them sound
like a group of companies that have come
together to sign some fancy legal
documents which I suppose in a way they
have there isn't a legal document
binding them together there is simply
survival the word Consortium can mean a
lot of things in the microbial World in
part because our understanding of what
they are is currently evolving but also
they're just a lot of different contexts
in which they seem to appear when the
term was first introduced to the
microcosmos realm in 1872 by naturalist
Johannes renke the idea was to describe
how an organism can actually be made
made up of two species that have somehow
found a unified body to live in
organisms like lichen made up of algae
and fungi but the specific ways that
organisms intertwine their lives can
vary and for our purposes today the
definition that probably best applies is
that a Consortium is a group of bacteria
that are organized and are in permanent
contact with one another
there are various types of consortia
that scientists know about including
formations that live in your own mouth
these consortia can be distinguished
from one another by their color and
their shape the number of cells within
them and the shape of those cells and
what makes them all special is that
these are relationships formed entirely
between prokaryotes this sets consortia
apart from other Ventures into bacterial
symbiosis that we have explored which
have generally involved bacteria seeking
out more complex eukaryotic partners for
example there are bacteria that live on
the surface of the ciliate kentroforos
so they can hitch a ride to Regions with
enough hydrogen sulfide for them to
convert into food so this property of
consortia only being relationships
between prokaryotes makes this really
fascinating to scientists for a few
reasons one is simply that bacteria
probably teamed up with each other
before they ever teamed up with
eukaryotes and understanding how they
formed these relationships may help us
better grasp how they have evolved with
the world around them consortia offer
more than just history though they also
might suggest different futures for us
providing us with the means to
understand how we can use bacteria for
everything from farming to cleaning up
oil spills
but identifying and understanding these
consortia is challenging James our
master of microscopes has been baffled
by what looks like a bunch of logs glued
together he thought there might be
flagellates in there along with the
prokaryotes but when he tried separating
the individuals he couldn't find any so
for now like most of the consortia we've
been looking at the mechanics of this
group remain unclear to us perhaps the
best studied Consortium is
chlorochromatium aggregatum the small
green group we watched in the beginning
of this episode they are found in lakes
and ponds typically in areas with low
amounts of oxygen and light the green
bacteria are chlorobium chlorochromatii
a green sulfur bacteria that are
photosynthetic but that are surprisingly
Adept at living in low light situations
and yet they do still need light which
would be fine except that green silver
bacteria have a problem problem they
cannot swim there are ways around this
problem like the green sulfur bacteria
that just go up in the water column by
producing gas vacuoles it's like balloon
travel in the micro Cosmos and much like
actual balloon travel it can take a few
days for the bacteria to get where they
want to go so not always the optimal
choice
but that is not a problem for chlorobium
chlorochromatii because they have found
a different way to get around the micro
Cosmos a colorless rod-shaped bacteria
called candidatis symbiobacter mobilis
now we don't have a good view of this
organism because in most of our videos
it's surrounded by the green sulfur
bacteria that have latched onto it but
here you can get a glimpse of it in the
middle of green bacteria assembling a
Consortium around it the job of that
Central bacterium is to move surrounded
by anywhere from 20 to 70 of its green
sulfur bacteria companions the bacterium
in the middle of all of it takes the
group to light and to sulfite and these
Consortium members might be in
communication with each other to find
the light
but why would candidates symbiobacter
mobilis agree to this relationship well
the most likely explanation is that they
get nutrients from their companions
now that is truly The Exchange being
made then it is a trade that has had a
huge impact on that Central bacterium
when scientists study the genomes of
both chlorobium chlorochromatii and
candidata symbiobacter mobilis they
found that the green sulfur bacteria
didn't seem to have changed much to make
the symbiosis happen a few genes they'd
acquired that were geared towards
symbiosis helped make the cells adhere
to each other or changed the cell wall a
little bit in contrast candidata
symbiobacter mobilis seems to have lost
a large number of its genes so much so
that it cannot grow independently it
needs the Consortium to survive and only
when the Consortium divides can it
divide as well when you say it like that
the Consortium sounds almost like a
dystopian entity one that's trapped the
candidata symbiobacter mobilis into a
life of shuttling green sulfur bacteria
around with no mind to its own needs
though I couldn't that be said for any
of our own cells they don't get to live
their own lives or divide at will if
they do our immune system will kill them
because uncontrolled cell division is
very dangerous to the larger organism
this Consortium is in a way a holy other
kind of organism one that you likely
have never even heard of at its heart is
a species of prokaryote that cannot
survive outside of it the closer you
look the more you realize life does not
let us draw hard lines around anything
it simply does what works
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and if you want to
open your eyes to the bizarre world that
is just outside your door and also in
your own body don't forget to check out
microcosmos dot store we just want to
bring more people into this amazing
community so check it out and maybe you
can pick up your own microscope or if
you just want to show your love for
microscopy and microscopic organisms we
have things like Hydra shirts and
tardigrade mugs and micro bumper
stickers that you can pick up to let
everyone around you know that you are a
tardigrade enthusiast
the people on the screen right now they
are our patreon patrons they're the
people who let us and allow us and
enable us to make this content we're so
grateful for them I really love that we
get to make this show and that I along
with you get to keep learning more and
more about the micro Cosmos so thank you
so much to all those people if you want
to become one of them you can go to
patreon.com journey to micro if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss check out jam
and germs on Instagram and if you want
to see more from us there's always a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
thank you
[Music]
foreign